SARA MURRAY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SARA'S BREAKING THAT NEWS.
I WANT TO GO TO THE FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE ATTORNEY TY COBB.
THERE IS SO MUCH GOING ON RIGHT
NOW AS WE SPEAK RELATED TO
MULTIPLE CASES THAT APPEAR TO AT
THIS POINT TARGET THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
A LOT OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE
QUESTIONING WHETHER THE MAJOR
STEP BY THE FBI TO SEARCH
MAR-A-LAGO, THE HOME OF A FORMER
PRESIDENT, AN UNPRECEDENTED
MOVE, FITS THE CRIME.
THE POTENTIAL CRIME, THAT IS PUT
OUT THERE OF MISHANDLING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
NOW, YOU THINK THERE IS MORE
HERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS IS ABOUT,
TY?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S ABOUT THE
UNDERLYING BIG LIE AND THE
JANUARY 6th.
I DON'T BELIEVE -- I'M HIGHLY
CONFIDENT THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
BUT IT COULD EASILY BE ABOUT THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, QUITE
LIKELY CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT
ARE OF GREAT INTEREST TO THE
BUREAU AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, WHICH THEY HAVE
APPARENTLY PRESSED FOR, AND IT
ALSO APPEARS THERE'S A BIT OF A
COMMUNICATION BREAKDOWN BETWEEN
TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, AS I
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS, THERE
HAVE BEEN REPETITIVE PRODUCTIONS
AND ACCESS TO DOCUMENTS ALLOWED
TO DOJ AND FBI OFFICIALS, BUT
SOMETHING BROKE DOWN.
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> SOMETHING, AND OBVIOUSLY
SOMETHING REALLY SERIOUS BROKE
DOWN.
BACK TO THE QUESTION I RAISED TO
FORMER DIRECTOR McCABE, THEY
WERE HANDING OVER INFORMATION.
DID THEY POSSIBLY KNOW THE
NEEDLE IN THE HAYSTACK THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR AND THEN IT KEPT NOT
BEING IN THE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
PRODUCED?
IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, TY, IS YOU THINK
SOMEHOW, WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR HERE MAY HAVE BEEN
CLASSIFIED, MAY HAVE NOT BEEN
CLASSIFIED, BUT LEADS TO JANUARY
6th, IS RELATED TO THAT
INVESTIGATION?
>> I BELIEVE SO.
I THINK THAT'S THE BIG
ENCHILADA.
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT WOULD BE
TRULY BIZARRE TO BRING A PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT CHARGE AGAINST A
FORMER PRESIDENT AS THE FIRST
TIME IN HISTORY OF INDICTING A
FORMER PRESIDENT.
BECAUSE THAT IS JUST -- THAT'S
THE TYPE OF THING THAT JUST
DOESN'T RISE TO THE LEVEL OF
STRESS FOR THE CONSTITUTION AND
THE DEMOCRACY.
BUT THE JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION AND THE BIG LIE
AND ITS PERPETUATION, THERE'S
CLEARLY EVIDENCE, CONSEQUENTIAL
EVIDENCE OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY,
AND YESTERDAY I BELIEVE JUDGE
REINHARDT PUT HIS HAND TO THAT
AND AGREED.
>> SO YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING, TY,
WITH ME ABOUT GEORGIA, OTHER
PLACES.
YOU DO BELIEVE THAT TRUMP IS
FACING SIGNIFICANT LEGAL
EXPOSURE ON SEVERAL FRONTS.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT NOW IN
LIGHT OF WHERE WE ARE AND THIS
IS A DIFFERENT WORLD THAN IT WAS
25 HOURS AGO, DO YOU THINK THIS
IS LEADING CLOSER TO AN
INDICTMENT OF TRUMP HIMSELF NOW?
>> EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN DONE
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS, DOES THAT
MEAN HE'LL ACTUALLY BE INDICTED?
YOU DON'T KNOW.
WILL THERE BE NEGOTIATIONS?
IF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DECIDES TO INDICT HIM, I WOULD
ASSUME SO, BUT IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT TOO MANY BRIDGES HAVE BEEN
BROKE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU MENTIONED
GEORGIA, AND ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS IN GEORGIA IS THE FAKE
ELECTORS AND THE WHOLE PROCESS
OF HOW THE STATE VOTING WAS TO
BE REPORTED TO PENCE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK SCOTT PERRY'S
SEIZURE TODAY IS EQUALLY
INTERESTING BECAUSE IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE INTRUSION BETWEEN TWO
OF THE PILLARS OF OUR DEMOCRACY,
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND
CONGRESS, FOR THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH TO USE ITS AUTHORITY TO
GET A SEARCH WARRANT FOR A
CONGRESSMAN'S PROPERTY.
>> TY, BEFORE WE GO, ONE
QUESTION BECAUSE YOU WORKED WITH
THE PRESIDENT, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW HIM, YOU HAVE SEEN HIM
WITH DOCUMENTS.
STEPHANIE GRIXM WAS SAYING LAST
NIGHT AS THIS BROKE, SHE HAD
BEEN WITH HIM WHERE HE WOULD
THROW THINGS AWAY.
PUT CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN HIS
POCKET.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IF THERE
WERE ANY DOCUMENT THAT WAS SOME
SORT OF A SMOKING GUN OR
SOMETHING RELATED TO JANUARY 6th
THAT HE WAS AWARE OF, HE WOULD
HAVE IT AT MAR-A-LAGO AT THIS
POINT?
>> YEAH, IT DOESN'T MAKE HIM
MUCH OF A CALCULATED CRIMINAL,
DOES IT, IF HE STILL HAD
POSSESSION OF IT?
ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU CAN'T BE
SURE.
HE WAS AT LEAST RECKLESS IN
TERMS OF NOT FOLLOWING
INSTRUCTIONS FROM WHITE HOUSE
PERSONNEL ABOUT TEARING UP
DOCUMENTS AND STUFF.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, PEOPLE
WOULD CLEAN OUT THE TRASH CANS
EVERY NIGHT AND TAPE STUFF BACK
TOGETHER.
AND I NEVER SAW ANY KETCHUP ON
THE WALL, SO I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE STUFF THAT STEPHANIE
TALKED ABOUT, BUT YES, I KNOW
HE'S SORT OF DISMISSIVE OF MANY
PROTOCOLS, BUT I DIDN'T EVER
KNOW HIM TO HIDE OR DESTROY